incident warfare has been revealed but
it's not the only call of duty game
we're getting this year the rumors about
modern warfare coming to current
consoles are true call of duty modern
warfare remastered is on its way this
fault Infinity Ward released the
original modern warfare back in 2007 and
their executive producing the remaster
with Raven Software handling development
it'll include modern warfare full
campaign as well as multiplayer although
the multiplayer will be limited to 10
fan favorite maps and of course the
whole thing will feature improved
textures lighting particles and audio
modern warfare remastered is coming to
ps4 xbox one and pc on november fourth
the same day is infinite warfare that's
because the only way to get it is to
pick up infinite Warfare's digital
deluxe legacy or legacy pro edition if
Activision announces a standalone
package for modern warfare remastered
will definitely tell you about it in the
meantime for all the call of duty news
you need you already in the right place